[Music]
to get started I just want to tell you
all something that I truly feel from
from the heart I really love these kind
of events and I want to thank each and
every one of you for being here because
these events are really really useful
and effective ways for us to talk to
customers so every time we come to a
Google next like for instance when we
came here last year we had this
opportunity to come talk to all of you
and listen to some of your feedback
about what's working well what's not
what can we change what can we do better
what should we continue to focus on and
we take all of this feedback and then we
go back to our work day jobs and we
start looking at all of this and of
course we take a little bit of a break
in between but we go back the next week
and we start looking at all of these
lists of things that we heard from you
in terms of what's working well and
what's not and we use this to kind of be
a roadmap for the next year so we really
focus on areas where you say we're doing
well and areas where you say we need to
improve and try to make something that
really helps solve those problems and
that's where I'm really excited to come
back here today and talk to you about
what we learned last year and what we've
been able to deliver in terms of things
that help simplify your lives and our
you know help build on our partnership
so with that I want to start off by
saying what were some of the key things
that we heard from all of you last year
so we heard various things from you but
if I were to distill them down onto one
slide these are some of the key pain
points that you talked about one of the
things we heard a lot was you wanted us
to meet you variable you wanted us to
make it easier for you to get onto the
cloud or to reach the cloud and as you
might have noticed in today's keynote a
lot of what we've done over the past
year has been in that very area where we
talked about bringing the cloud to you
rather than kind of having you move
things over or looking at things in a
different way the second thing that
we've heard a lot from people was help
simplify my transition it doesn't matter
whether you are trying to transition a
whole bunch of workloads
or you're trying to transition just a
small small pieces of things that you're
running somewhere into
Google flower so you asked us to help
simplify that transition and that has
been one of our key focuses as well and
I'll definitely go into some interesting
ways we've been able to do that you also
got two really nice pieces of feedback
you said that you really like how we
price things and how flexible we are in
terms of costs and making off the
offerings available in a very very cost
effective manner and we also heard from
you that we do really well when it comes
to security and trying to provide a nice
footprint and a nice kind of ecosystem
that lets you build your security story
on top of that and so we've double down
on both of these areas and try to do
more to help make these more useful and
more better for you so with that I'm
gonna start off by talking about
something that we at Google cloud really
feel is a big differentiator for us and
it's something that we focus on and we
want to continue to focus on and that is
our global infrastructure so look Google
cloud has been building this
infrastructure for many many years from
even before when we were Google cloud so
we've been building these submarine
cables and we've been building these
data centers and we've gotten to this
point where this year we're so proud to
announce that you know we've we have 17
regions that are up and we have a
hundred and twenty-five points of
presence around the globe and this goes
to make that transition to the cloud
much easier because each and every one
of these points of presence is one
additional location that's closer to
where your customers are your customers
who are consuming your applications
which run in Google Cloud and what we do
to tie all of this together is we have
this extensive network of submarine
cables and terrestrial cables that
connect all of these points of presence
and our data centers and various other
pieces that we provide for you together
to make it one huge infrastructure
investment that delivers value to all of
you and over the years as we've been
building these subsea cables and all of
these investments that we made in the
cable world have gotten gotten us to the
point where we have extends an extensive
team that's completely focused on
submarine cables and I'm really really
proud to talk about the next slide which
is something very unique that we did
this year so in January of this year we
became the first non
telco company to announce a completely
private subsea cable that connects two
continents and this was the curie subsea
Cable named after Mary Curie and it
connects Los Angeles to Chile and I'm
also very very excited to announce that
well not announced but last week we
announced the Dunant subsea cable this
is again named after the founder of the
Red Cross Andre do not and it connects
the east coast of the US to Europe so
this is the first transatlantic cable
that's actually again owned completely
privately by a non telco entity so this
just goes to show some of these things
that we are trying to do to bring more
value from our infrastructure to you so
just looking at the numbers in terms of
what we've been doing with respect to
infrastructures I'm going to point out a
few key numbers here we've been spending
a lot of money in terms of making this
infrastructure that underlies our Google
cloud and over the past three years
we've spent over 30 billion dollars in
terms of expenses to build out Google's
infrastructure in addition we also got
20 cloud regions that we've announced we
have a hundred and twenty-five points of
presence which I talked about we're
going to go into the dedicated
interconnection interconnect locations
shortly as well but the really
interesting statistic here is the
hundred thousand miles of fiber optic
cable that we have this is if you look
at all of the subs all of the fiber
optic cables that we've deployed across
the globe it's a hundred thousand miles
that's just to put it in context about a
little bit over a third of the distance
from here to the moon so it's a lot of
investment in terms of these cables and
I what I hope to do is to tell you a
little bit about why this adds value to
you and your deployments running on
Google cloud so all of this
infrastructure is the underlay that lets
us build our Sdn ecosystem on top of
that using things that you've probably
heard about like Andromeda and espresso
and if you want to learn more about this
I definitely recommend that you go and
attend one of two sessions that we have
later in the conference which dive a
much dive much deeper into this area and
about how it helps improve performance
of different workloads that are running
in the cloud and in terms of networking
how it makes it so efficient but if I
were to point out key three key things
here the first thing is this lets us
provide this global
network and the construct of the global
VP see that I'll talk about in a minute
which basically takes away a lot of your
sprawl and toil from managing a vast
cloud deployment it gives you a global
reach by getting you to a point very
very close to where your customers are
and it also gives you various benefits
like live migration with live migration
what they're able to do is were able to
keep your VMs up when we need to do
something like say a firmware update
that needs to be done on the underlying
infrastructure and some of these things
really make it very easy to deploy on
Google cloud and help your workloads
keep running and finally because of the
way we have all of this infrastructure
investment laid out and we have we have
these this Sdn architecture built on top
of that it also helps things scale
seamlessly because every single piece of
our networking offering is built in such
a way that there are no choke points
everything is built in a distributed
manner to make it very very easy for you
to scale and we've continued to innovate
in this area with something that we
announced late last year which was
Andromeda 2.1 which has actually reduced
our intra zonal latency by 40 percent
from Andromeda 2.0 and that's if you
look at it overall it's about a seven
hundred and eighty percent reduction in
terms of the latency going from when we
originally started and introduced
Andromeda so we talked about this
infrastructure now let me go a little
bit deeper into how this infrastructure
helps you build your cloud deployments
and we're going to look at some
interesting things we've done over the
past year and how we help solve various
of those problems that we talked about
in the beginning so to begin with I want
to talk about two pieces our virtual
private cloud and our connectivity
options so when you look at Google
clouds VPC the global VPC that we
provide it's very very unique in the
sense that it provides you a
connectivity by default across all of
your workloads that are running in that
you have running in Google cloud no
matter which region you're on so what I
have there is a simple one-sentence way
if I were to describe this the way I
would do that is you you may have 17
regions you may have VMs running in each
and every one of these 17 regions but
you have one VPC which means you have to
manage one set of policies you have to
manage one set of security you need to
do all of your security
and everything once and it really makes
it much easier for you to manage your
global a truly global deployment now the
other really nice thing about this is
since this is built in this way the only
way we are able to make something like
this work is because of the
infrastructure offerings that we provide
that gives you the kind of performance
that you really need to pull something
off like this now let's look at what are
some different things that you can do to
connect to the global V PC from your
network so we've had various offerings
and this year we talked about two key
offerings which was the Google cloud
interconnect offerings and when you look
at Google cloud interconnect what it
does is these are various offerings that
help you connect from wherever you are
whether it's a data center or whether
you're looking at a colocation facility
it gives you a convenient way for you to
connect from where you are to Google
cloud and the way you would do this is
you would connect to one of our many
dedicated interconnect points of
presence and once you do that you will
be on the Google cloud network for the
rest of the way the other interesting
thing I want to quickly touch upon
before diving deeper into Google cloud
interconnect is we have also been
working on simplifying all of your
connectivity options including VPN we've
had a lot of efforts that we've invested
in working with our partners and with
our partners we've been able to deliver
this whole slew of integration guides
and making it extremely easy for you to
spin up any kind of VPN connectivity
when you want to connect to Google
flower so I mentioned about dedicated
interconnect so let me tell you what we
think makes dedicated interconnect
unique so when you look at a
connectivity option where you need to
connect to a cloud let's imagine that
you have a data center here in San
Francisco
and you have workloads that are running
in different regions let's say you have
one running in Los Angeles you have one
running in Singapore and you have one
running somewhere in Europe so just pick
any three data centers of your choice
and imagine that you have this deployed
now if you were trying to do a dedicated
connectivity from your data center to
the cloud to each one of these regions
usually you would have to deploy one
connect one set of connections to each
and every one of these regions with
dedicated interconnect what you're able
to do is you're actually able to connect
from your data center to the nearest
region so in this case you would just
connect to the Los Angeles region
and from there you can write Google's
backbone to get to whichever other data
center that you need to the other really
nice thing about this is it greatly
simplifies the sprawl and toil that will
come from trying to build these kind of
deployments with multiple connections
going to all of these different regions
so these are a this map shows all of our
dedicated interconnect locations so no
matter where you are there are these
various locations where you need to get
to and we will bring you on to the
Google cloud network right from those
points we also work with various
partners and each and every one of these
partners helps us get helps us provide
you with a much more simplified way of
connecting to Google cloud so for
instance if you were to connect to any
one of these partners you get the
flexibility to choose the bandwidth that
you need and they will help you connect
from wherever you are
to Google cloud so we talked about how
we've been trying to simplify your
connectivity options when you try to go
from your on-premise to the cloud now
let's look at what we've been doing in
terms of helping you deliver your
applications better so then you talk
about application delivery these are a
few offerings that we usually talk about
and I'm going to spend a few minutes
talking about what we have done in each
of these over the past year so first
let's take a look at Google clouds
global load balancing so we we built
Google clouds global load balancing
based off all over all of the lessons
that we learnt over the years in terms
of building and delivering applications
like Gmail and Google search and YouTube
and all of these different offerings and
you'll also notice that that's actually
true for each and every one of these
things that we look at in the
application delivery portfolio and when
you see this we we got a lot of great
feedback in terms of how the Google
cloud load balancer works and how it
makes it extremely simple to manage a
scalable load balancing deployment and
we've kind of tried to take that over
the last year and go to the next step so
our Google cloud load balancer for those
of you who aren't familiar with it
supports global anycast IP load
balancing which means rather than having
to use your DNS service to load balance
to multiple IP addresses depending on
where your traffic is coming from you
can use your load balancer to use a
single global anycast
IP so that if you have a user for
instance in this example who is trying
to get onto the Google cloud network to
reach your application
San Francisco they would still be using
the same ip address as you would see for
a customer who's trying to connect to
your Google cloud deployment from
Singapore but the services will be
provided by the data center that's
closest to them so this does various
things and the first and foremost is it
greatly simplifies what you need to do
on the DNS front in terms of configuring
and managing a deployment like this now
the really cool thing that we've done in
this area in the past year is we
enhanced a lot of different protocol
supports that we've added over the past
year and one of them specifically that I
want to call out is our support for
quick so quick actually is a is a
protocol that would help you gain a lot
in terms of your connectivity time and
in terms of the latency that it actually
takes for your users to get on to this
application that you're looking for so
for instance we see about an 8% increase
decrease in terms of page load times
globally and especially if you're in an
area where there is a lot of latency
you're in or you're in a high latency
environment it goes up much higher it's
about 13% in those kind of areas so we
do have a great session about load
balancing that's happening later in the
conference as well where we will go much
deeper into this area and many other
things about our load balancing offering
Google Cloud DNS is built to work with
our load balancers so it works out
really really well in this particular
deployment where it integrates
seamlessly with our global anycast load
balancing offering it also has a very
very simple scalable record management
and it also supports DNS sex so that you
can verify the integrity of your records
when you connect when your clients are
trying to connect to your setup now
let's look at Google clouds content
delivery network so like I mentioned our
content delivery system as well is built
off of a lot of the things that we've
learnt over the years from YouTube and
Google search and all of our other
offerings and what we've been able to do
here is to try and take some of those
lessons and bring to you a very very
scalable global approach to delivering
your content across the globe so one
thing that we've done over the past year
is we recently announced support for
very very large sized objects which
makes it great for media and sea and
applications where you are trying to
either deliver media or gaming so this
is again something great that we're that
we're very very proud of and we do have
a session about CDN as well if
interested in learning more about this
offering we announced Network tears at
next last year network leaders is now in
beta and network layers is basically
what makes your global V PC work so the
network tears is an offering that lets
your traffic travel Google's network all
all the way through from the source to
your end user until a point of presence
it's very very close to them so by doing
this it's able to provide you with much
better latency and much better
performance then you will be used to on
a regular when you are using the public
internet so we do also so last year we
heard from you that in some times there
are certain workloads where this extra
performance is not necessarily what you
are looking for and you would look for
more cost-effective offering so that's
where we introduced the standard here
and the standard here is currently beta
and usually when you look at customers
and when they use premium network versus
standard Network our customers really
like to use the premium network for any
live applications or applications that
are being accessed by their end users
whereas in a lot of cases they like to
use the standard network for things like
a test deployment where you are trying
to build something and making changes in
your development environment so those
kind of environments usually use the
standard network as opposed to the
premium network for their production
environment now we talked about
connecting to the cloud and we talked
about delivering your applications to
your customers next we're going to look
at various things that we've been doing
in the area of securing our deployments
so we got a lot of great feedback in
terms of how we've been making more and
more offerings available in terms of
security for our users and in this area
we focus on a few specific things to try
and make those very very user friendly
and very very easy so the first one is V
PC service controls so what V PC service
controls does is it greatly mitigates
any kind of exfiltration risk you may
have by providing you controls which are
context aware and let you enforce policy
for accessing files not just based on
the identity of the user but also based
on the context so this gives you much
more visibility into your data which is
the lifeblood of your business and it
really helps you control where this data
is flowing
network monitoring is one area where we
got a lot of feedback from our customers
saying that when you look at a cloud
deployment and you look at network
monitoring offerings that are available
there one big concern for for our
customers was that it doesn't map one to
one when you get started in terms of
what we have with network with the level
of visibility that you look at in the
cloud as opposed to what you look at
when you're doing something on Prem and
so we took that and we've gone we went
back and we try to build as offering and
we announced VPC flow logs which is now
generally available and with VPC flow
logs what you can do is you get five
second interval updates so this is close
to as it's almost as flat it's almost as
responsive as what you could see on your
in your data centers and the really nice
thing about doing something like this is
it lets you have the same level of
visibility that you would when you're
deploying things in your data center and
it integrates seamlessly with all of
your deployments that you have on Prem
as well because we partner with many of
our security partners to provide
visibility into these logs so what you
could do is you could export these logs
to your partner ecosystem that you're
already using and have a single pane of
glass where you can visualize both your
data both your traffic in your data
center as well as what you are using in
the cloud and what helps us make this
even more flexible is that we have a
very very rich set of parameters that we
provide to you in terms of filtering
these this flow log so we let you
annotate based on things like the
geolocation of your client who's trying
to access the service the region where
your VMs running and various other
things like the subnet and various other
things that let you get the logs that
you're really looking for and just use
those in order to look at your keep a
close eye on your and get great
visibility into the security posture of
your deployment the next thing we're
going to talk about is cloud armor cloud
armor is our denial of service defense
system that we've built and we announced
in March this year and in fact we have a
session later this later today where
Nick will also be presenting about the
target and how they have been using the
cloud armor service as well
so there are a few key things I want to
point out about cloud Hartman so cloud
armor is built to integrate
very very closely with our load balancer
so what tends to happen is we are able
to take away a brunt of any kind of a
layer 3 DDoS attack that would try to
hit you at the load balancer then beyond
that we have denial of service defense
that is built to protect you against
application attacks and various things
like SQL like SQL injection and
cross-site scripting so cloud admin
provides you with a rules language that
lets you program things beyond things
like SQL injection and cross-site
scripting where you can tailor your
security policy to fit exactly what
you're doing on your deployment and the
nice thing about the way cloud armor is
built is that it happens a lot of this
protection is or a lot of this defense
actually happens at the perimeter which
means you it so it makes it much easier
for you to manage the scale of your
setup while using something like cloud
armor so we talked about all of these
different offerings we talked about our
connectivity offerings the security that
we try to provide to you with your
networking deployments how you can get
your applications delivered to your
customer so in this next section I'm
going to talk about the workload of your
choice so we have been having more and
more customers adopt kubernetes and we
have a lot of customers who have been
adopting gke
and they're really adopting the
container technologies and making them
their own so what we've been focusing on
is we've been trying to make google
cloud the cloud of choice to run your
micro services so we are trying to
provide native support for every single
networking service that we have and
networking offering that we have for
kubernetes engine like for instance this
year we have support kubernetes engine
supports global load balancing it
supports our denial of service product
which is cloud armor it it supports IP
and our CDN and and we are committed to
making sure that every one of our
networking offerings is available for
you with kubernetes engine as well and
people also taken the next step in terms
of securing kubernetes workloads so that
you can look at your security whether
you're looking at containers or you're
looking at compute you can look at them
in the same way so we announced support
for things like shared EPC private
clusters we support network policies
distributed firewalls VPC flow logging
all of these are supported natively now
with kubernetes which makes it extremely
easy
for you the manager security policies
whether you're doing compute engine or
container engine deployments and if
you're looking to connect your different
services I'm sure you already heard
about some of this in today morning's
keynote and you're gonna hear a lot more
over the next few days in terms of
various sessions where people are going
to talk to you about sto and kubernetes
and what they're doing in these areas to
really make it easy to use manage and
secure and to this point we also have we
also have support for all of these
things in different ways in our
networking offerings so like for
instance we also you know in our
networking team we also have the G RPC
under our portfolio which lets you
secure communication which lets you
connect basically your services in terms
of RPC calls and making sure that it's
extremely easy for you to build a
service without having to put all the
brunt of the effort of building and
deploying the networking aspects of this
on your developers so what you can do is
you can use ecosystems like sto and G
RPC and make it available to your
developers so that they can focus on
building the applications without having
to worry a lot about the networking and
securing their network communication
paths which can be taken care of then by
your security admins who would use tools
like SEO and G RPC to make sure that
this communication is secured we also
have a lot of partners in the areas of
security and we're working with adding
many many more every day we we keep
talking to different partners and we try
to see how we can integrate with them to
make a better offering available to you
every single day and so this is just a
quick snapshot of various partners that
we have in the security space and I'm
sure you'll recognize a lot of names
there so we do work with them very very
closely to make Google cloud a very very
partner friendly offering when it comes
to network security so with that I just
want to recap by saying that thank you
so much for all the feedback that you
gave us in the last year and it's really
helped us empower your success by trying
to come and make it easier for you to
move to the cloud by meeting you where
you are and providing you these secure
and flexible yet simple and reliable
offerings that can really work for any
workload that you're looking to use and
with that I definitely want to also say
looking forward to talking to all of you
and hearing what you have in mind for us
for the next year and what you would
like to hear about when we come back to
next 2019 next year so now I'm gonna
call Nick on stage to come and talk
about what a lot of these offerings
meant from a customer perspective all
right hi everyone
my name is Nick Jakes I am a lead
engineer at Target and I work on our
cloud platform team I'm really excited
to be here today and chat with everyone
about some of the things that we're
doing in GCP so just a little bit about
who I am and what target is so target is
a rather popular retailer here in the US
we have 1,800 stores several
distribution centers a few headquarters
locations and then we also have one very
big virtual store Target calm I've been
working on our cloud platform team for
about two and a half three years now
and prior to that I was on a couple of
our different infrastructure teams
dealing with enterprise storage and
virtualization private cloud build-out
all kinds of good stuff like that the
reason why we thought it'd be really
appropriate to share some of this with
you is target started its journey and
GCP in early 2017 so it's been a little
over a year since we've really been have
migrated to GCP and earnest so we
thought that kind of lined up with the
discussion about what's new over the
past year in GCP just to give you a
little timetable in very early 2017 is
when we started migrating our workloads
from another cloud provider into GCP and
we were able to complete that I want to
say around late July mid August so right
in time for peak season we had a very
successful peak season with no issues
and everyone was really happy about that
early this year we had discussions
around where we were going to migrate
our commerce workloads so if we kind of
split these into two categories
what non commerce means for us is when
you're on target.com or if you're using
one of our apps it's basically anything
that doesn't involve purchasing products
so if you're looking searching for
products if you're swiping through
looking at images of products things
like that that's what we call non
commerce and then when we actually have
you add items to your cart checkout and
then pay for those items those are kind
of the commerce things those tend to be
a little more difficult
to do because there's quite a bit of
regulatory compliance involved with them
so we started migrating our commerce
workloads in earnest right around the
middle of this year probably around
March or April and actually we're almost
100% complete with that so we're pretty
excited that we have almost all the
things that power target calm in GCP
right now
so just to give you kind of the gamut of
what's in there we have quite a bit
that's there a lot of these services
that I list under target comm are
actually shared and our mobile apps use
those services to display content as
well but we have everything from our
adaptive front end so basically giving
you responsive design depending on what
you're using desktop laptop tablets
mobile devices things like that and also
our back ends our back ends kind of
spread the gamut between things that are
very monolithic they're kind of
stand-alone apps to some very
complicated applications that have
upwards of three or four dozen
micro-services we also operate a data
persistence layer and provide
replication services to and from our
data center and a platform for logging
and metrics these last three items the
data persistence replication and logging
and metrics are part of what we refer to
as platform services and that's part of
what my team helps offer our application
teams or our tenants and GCP we provide
a suite of services that any application
team can use and basically provides
common functionality around any cloud
that we deploy to so it abstracts a lot
of the difficulties away from our
application teams in terms of figuring
out how to do service discovery where to
store data how to replicate data things
like that and really lets them focus on
building their apps and then deploying
those apps and not really having to
worry about some of that underlying
infrastructure and then as I mentioned
we also operate some of our commerce
stuff in GCP and so those things are PCI
DSS compliant which obviously means that
there's a great deal of regulatory
compliance that's attached to it and
those environments are highly segmented
for our mobile apps so in addition to
everything that we just talked about for
target comm we also have some unique
mobile offerings so we have things like
cartwheel which is part of our mobile
app that lets you discover coupons and
various discounts that are available in
the store
wallet which is actually really great it
allows you to take all those coupons and
discounts that you discover with
cartwheel and pay with your red card in
a single scan of a barcode so it's
really handy I use it all the time and
then we also provide some other
interesting services like in-store
mapping so we can tell you where a
particular product is that you're
searching for in a store and then
actually show where you are in the store
you can kind of find your way to that
product there's a few other mobile apps
as well and then we also host on a
variety of API endpoints so we actually
host our developer documentation at
developer.android.com tent so think
images JavaScript files all kinds of
stuff like that in GCS buckets and we
also use cloud DNS so I sat for a while
and tried to think about how can I best
communicate all the various features
that we use in terms of networking and
infrastructure in GCP and I thought for
a while about this and ultimately what I
decided to do is turn to a tool that a
lot of people use in large companies
when they're making decisions which is a
particular geometric shape that tends to
be or have magical properties so I
looked at this and I definitely didn't
make this on a plane this is very
official and what I saw is that word
cloud for the eighth year is dominating
the information density representation
so with that in mind here are some of
the features that we use in terms of
networking and infrastructure for target
so there's quite a few up here I'm not
going to go through them all now because
we'll actually kind of just naturally go
through those as we work through these
slides so briefly what I want to talk
about are the environments that we have
so as I mentioned our non commerce
environment has to do a lot with
basically browsing and discovering
products and services on target.com so
the way those are structured we have
several environments so we have a dev
environment a non prod for staging and
performance purposes environments and
then we have a production environment
and you can think of those environments
basically as single monolithic projects
inside of those projects there's a
single V PC that contains many different
regional subnets and what we've done is
something kind of interesting here one
of the challenges we previously
encountered in Prior cloud providers and
just due to the nature of target itself
is IP address exhaustion so particularly
in a cloud you want to be able to scale
and not run into any issues where you've
exhausted a subnet and now what do you
do so to get around those challenges
because these tenants are actually quite
large in size and scale through many
thousands of instances is we actually
kind of divorced the application subnets
from our data center route ability so
what that means is all of our
applications that operate in our non
commerce environment are basically
air-gapped from the data center but what
that means for us is we've created
several very large subnets so we don't
have to worry about partitioning off
specific applications and specific
subnets or things like that it's just a
very large general-purpose hosting
environment the way that we allow the
applications to talk to services in our
data center or replicate data across is
that platform services on suite of
components that I mentioned earlier
those services are data center routable
and so that's how we replicate that data
across and then the application teams
can consume it in GCP if we take a look
then at our commerce environment that
environment is actually quite different
yes it's still hosted in GCP and yes we
still have our platform services there
but many things beyond that are
different so for compliance purposes we
wanted to make sure that we had a highly
segmented environment here so what we've
done is we've actually created many
projects and we've used shared V PC and
V PC peering to give us that really
highly segmented environment and help us
partition off each individual
application that runs there in this
model all of our instances our data
center routable and we made that choice
because this environment is actually at
least an order of magnitude smaller than
our non commerce environment and many of
those applications have direct
requirements for synchronous or
asynchronous calls to our data center to
complete things like payment transact
and so on so we needed to give those
applications a way to directly hook into
the data center as I mentioned these
tenants are highly segmented and
basically everything in this environment
is subject to regulatory compliance
so obviously we wanted to make sure that
we got it right going through some of
the common patterns that we have across
both of these environments we currently
use IPSec VPN s to connect our data
centers to these particular environments
one of the things that we're looking at
which was mentioned just a bit ago is
partner interconnect and that's
something that we're investigating and
we'll be taking a deeper look at that
either later this year or early 2019 we
also use cloud DNS basically across all
of our environments in GCP and that
hosts the authoritative DNS for our
internal resources as well as our
external resources our developers are a
really big fan of this because this
means that they can use a common
consolidated terraform or positive to
create DNS entries for their
applications and they don't need to cut
tickets to another team to create DNS
entries and wait for another team to
complete those tasks so we really
empower our developers by letting them
create their DNS entries themselves for
any type of situation where instances
need to reach out to the internet and
this is actually fairly common
given that API target com is surfaced on
the Internet
we provide either an at or a proxy
service so these services are
instrumented with packet capturing
software and they basically allow us to
police traffic that's egressing our
cloud environment and take a look at
what's going on there so that we can
react to it should anything happen as I
mentioned several times already our
platform services are consistent across
all these environments we also use the
HTTP load balancers almost universally I
would say that there are probably six
load balancers that are not the l7 load
balancers we love them they're great
they give us an anycast IP address we
operate services in multiple regions and
all we do is why are those services up
to the same load balancer and away we go
we don't have to worry about is this IP
address in this region and how do we geo
locate our users
and make sure that they're going to the
region closest to them it's all handled
through that load balancer the way that
we let our application teams manage
their deployments and manage the
instances they're running on is through
an open-source tool called spinnaker
it's a really great tool and I would
highly encourage you to check it out if
you're if you're able to use it in your
particular environment it really takes
away a lot of the pain of creating a
deployment pattern you don't have to
worry about having people log into an
instance and run scripts or anything
like that basically you create some sort
of package install deliverable spinnaker
we'll bake that into an instance
template for you and then you can deploy
that as many times as you would like and
deploy multiple instance groups and it
makes things really easy so I would
highly recommend that one of the things
that we use fairly heavily is private IP
Google access the reason why we use this
heavily is almost every instance in GCP
that we operate does not have a public
or external IP address our naps and
proxies are there for that purpose and
so what we want to do is keep all of
that traffic especially traffic that's
destined to api's for example to GCS
just internal to our V pcs so we use
private IP Google access for that we
collect and analyze logs across all of
these environments and then finally we
use cloud armor and SSL policies to make
sure that our load balancers at the edge
match our security posture that we'd
like them to have so for instance only
accepting TLS version 1.2 connections
things like that so we've talked through
a lot of lists what I want to do is give
you a visual that we can take a look at
so at a very high level this is what our
non commerce environment looks like so
what we have in our application hosting
area that's not really pictured here are
several subnets that span multiple
regions but roughly what happens is we
have a layer seven load balancer that
Front's are various endpoints so it
could be an application with multiple
URL routes it could be just a single
purpose app or a micro service and then
that we have that partition for platform
services again so again there's things
like service discovery that we host in
their data persistence data replication
things
that then as pictured we have a VPN that
connects this environment to our data
center and you'll notice that we've
attached only the platform services
subnets to our data center the
application hosting subnets really only
talked to our platform services and
that's about it then finally the part
that we haven't touched on yet is what
do we do as requests that are inbound
how do we actually service requests from
either our guests or API calls or things
like that how this works is we have our
clients they might be our guests they
might be a third party that's using our
API and the first step is they'll hit
our CDN provider so our CDN provider is
effectively our edge and through there
and a variety of caching and web
application firewall layers eventually
we'll Traverse back into GCP and we'll
hit one of these load balancers that
represents the particular service that
we're hosting so that's kind of things
for our non commerce environment in a
nutshell if we go over to our commerce
commerce environment pay really close
attention because the picture is going
to look fairly similar but what you
notice is we have a lot more boxes down
here on the left-hand side so what we've
done is we've used shared VPC in what
we've done is we partitioned out each of
these applications into its own service
project so what that means is our
application teams through spinnaker have
a full rein in their service project to
do deployments that they would need to
do and they can look at all the logs
that are collected by a stack driver
this partitioning puts us in a really
good place we're in application teams
can't look at other app teams logs right
you can only see the logs that are
relevant to the workloads that are
operating in your project so that's been
working out very nicely for us we've
done the exact same thing with our
platform services as well so no one is
immune to the segmentation and
partitioning so each of our platform
services teams that operates each one of
these particular services that we
provide has their own service project as
well and then what we've done in the in
the great part about shared VPC is we
consolidated all of our network policy
into the host project so what that means
is all of our custom routes are there
our VPN connections are there but apply
to all of these service projects as well
and then our firewall rules are there as
well so the great thing about this is we
have a centralized place for fire
rulz we don't need to go hunting around
to see if a particular application team
has changed a firewall rule and in fact
the application teams can't change a
firewall rule because these service
projects won't allow it
so all those firewall rules are hosted
and kind of consolidated in the host
project and then we provide our
developers again a terraform repository
through which they can enact those
changes in this particular case they are
heavily reviewed and we ensure the
safety before we put those into effect
and then the rest of it is very similar
we have VPNs that connect us to the data
center in this case GCP side anything
can traverse the VPN and come back to
the target data center and then we have
a firewall on our side to make sure that
only the appropriate traffic is coming
back or going to GCP and then our
internet path over on the upper right is
basically the same as non commerce we
still use our CDN to direct the traffic
inbound for us okay so this was a really
high level what I want to do now is kind
of zoom in to just the GCP area a little
bit and show you what's what's going on
there and a little more detail so the
first thing we'll take a look at we kind
of sometimes jokingly refer to this as a
load balancer sandwich but for our
application teams what we do is we
obviously have the l7 load balancer at
the edge for public ingress and then we
actually have internal load balancers
that we use for connectivity either
inside the V PC or from our data center
up into GCP below what you'll see in the
platform services section is things got
a lot bigger we've talked about a lot of
these items already so just gloss over
this really quickly but a lot of these
services are common to each environment
and as I mentioned we have proxy and NAT
services available for these workloads
that need to reach out to the internet
where we do police that egress if we
take a look in the lower right and look
at the network section there are some
things that we use that are kind of
inherent across all of these
environments so we use cloud VPN and
cloud router together and what we
actually do in this in these scenarios
is we use BGP to announce the rows
across so this is really great this
saves us a lot of time from having to
try to figure out how we announce these
static routes and putting all these
change requests and makes things really
easy for us and it makes fail
over really easy for us as well we have
cloud firewall rules as I mentioned
which are inherent across all these
environments and there are many of them
and then we use custom routes to do
things like pull traffic destined to the
Internet
through our Nats so there really isn't a
good way for applications to egress out
any other way than through our nap in
the upper right we'll kind of just gloss
over these a little bit but we use many
other GCP offerings we can see a
sampling up there so we use I am very
heavily we use logging and cloud pub/sub
which has actually been very helpful to
us so what we do is we have logging
syncs on a lot of our stack driver
topics and we pull that into pub/sub and
then what we do at our data center is
subscribe to that topic and ingest that
so instead of clouding up or or filling
up our VPN tunnels to and from GCP we
basically transmit that out-of-band and
pull it into our data center where it's
logged stored and analyzed and then
finally the last piece that I want to
touch on Rd cloud armor and SSL policies
that we apply to all of our load
balancers at the edge to make sure that
we have consistency in the way that
those endpoints are accessed so just
quickly going through some highlights
things that have been really great for
us over the past year the global l7 load
balancers as I said earlier have been
really great we're big fans of it and I
don't think we really have any
complaints about it whatsoever inter
region networking has been great for us
so this was something that we were able
to adopt when we moved to GCP and it's
basically built in it's really quick
it's really easy we have absolutely no
complaints about it and for some of our
services so for example a lot of our
data persistence is stored in Cassandra
we can just replicate across regions
without having to worry about regional V
pcs and peering those V pcs together or
even going to the level of running VPNs
and those of epcs and then connecting
VPNs together to get traffic across them
so that's been great our IPSec VPNs have
been absolutely stable and we've had a
really great success with those the only
reason that we're looking at moving to
partner and interconnect excuse me is
need a little more bandwidth than what
the VPNs can currently provide us with
cloud armor has been fantastic that has
been in place in our commerce
environment since day one
and we're currently finishing a rollout
in our non commerce environment as well
a little tidbit that isn't talked about
very often is the NTP server that is
built into the metadata server so this
is great what it does is it gives you
access to Google's NTP servers and you
actually get the time smearing that
Google provides with their public time
Google com server as well so the great
thing here is we don't have to configure
anything this is all kind of baked in
and good to go and we don't have to
egress out to the internet for NTP sync
so that's been really handy private IP
Google access I touched on that already
that's been really great for us another
really great feature that thankfully
we've only run into one time is the
ability to expand yourself nuts live I
think a lot of folks know that no matter
how you plan and how many whiteboards
you draw on and how many spreadsheets
you fill out trying to set up your IP
space for a cloud deployment something
unexpected always happens and in those
cases what's actually really easy to do
in Google is if you haven't consumed the
space that you'll be expanding to you
can flip that slash 24 to a 23 or beyond
as long as that space is available and
you can do that live so it's a really
good way if the unexpected has happened
for you to get a little Headroom for
yourself and then finally cloud DNS
cloud DNS has been great for us and are
as I mentioned earlier developers love
it to kind of be in control of DNS and
do that in the self-service fashion so
then I want to just wrap up with our
lessons learned here one of the biggest
ones is that everyone should have and
exercise dr plans we have an internal
tool that we use that basically allows
us to go through all of our l7 load
balancers and disable traffic to a given
region we use this in emergency
situations or when we have issues with a
stack in those particular regions and
for the most part it's been working
really well typically within about 15 or
20 minutes after an incident is called
we're able to drain all of the ingress
traffic to a particular
region away and send that traffic to
other regions and we just do that with a
simple config change to the load
balancers so that's absolutely great
that we're able to respond in that way
if you're operating a hybrid cloud lots
of planning involved and a lots of
communicating with teams across the
organization we've been very lucky to
have really great partner teams at
target all the way from our
infrastructure teams that helped us set
up the VPNs through our platform
services teams that we partner with for
that data replication and storage all
the way up on through our app teams and
one of the things that we've done that's
been really critical is sat down with
our application teams and make sure that
as we're planning things out they're
included and we take their feedback into
account as we're building out these new
features for them one interesting item
is be careful of attaching the same
back-end service to multiple load
balancers we encounter this last year
when we had teams that when they're
operating in that load balancer sandwich
model created a single back-end service
and attached it to both and what
happened in that particular scenario is
the signals from the load balancers were
a little cross wired and they were not
able to scale that service based on our
PS from the layer 7 load balancer so if
scaling based on RPS is important to you
avoid attaching your back-end service to
multiple load balancers one other
interesting piece that has been a little
bit of an adaptation for our application
teams and our security teams is that
with the exception of cloud armor or the
network load balancer the firewall rules
that you apply are applied to the
instance itself I'm sorry this actually
does apply to network load balancer so
for il B's for instance there is no
firewall rule that you attach the I'll
be right
it's the firewall rule that you attach
the instance that actually allows that
traffic through the il beam so a little
bit of working to get that communicated
across all of our teams and then finally
just be wary no matter what you're doing
if they're static or dynamic
announcements of what routes you
announce back on premise we're lucky to
have BGP route filters in place on the
target side of things but we actually
for a period of time did wind up
announcing what is actually our internal
DMZ space
in our data centers that we use in GCP
as well and that's part of that kind of
separation that we operate our non
commerce applications in so luckily we
have those filters in place and nothing
bad happened but just be wary of that so
I think that about wraps it up for me
and I'll turn it back over oh sorry so
it kind of tying in with a couple other
things I'm sure you'll be hearing plenty
of announcements through the rest of
this conference and the rest of this
year some things that target is looking
forward to just a variety of
enhancements up here on the screen we
use ILP use quite heavily and cloud
armor quite heavily so we're looking
forward to some enhancements there we're
also looking forward to some additional
interconnect locations and one of the
big items that we're looking for is just
some general enhancements around V PC
performance and some of the managed
services that might be announced later
this year
so with that I'll send it back on over
thanks very much
[Music]